[Music]
[Applause]
george jones
the world's worst loser that sums up our
show that's five straight sports emmys
that we have lost
we have surpassed the buffalo bills they
went four in a row without winning a
super bowl
i think david spade won an award i think
he won an mtv award david spade actor
comedian tv host writer former saturday
night live cast member
got a netflix special nothing personal
got a great podcast with dana carvey
called fly on the wall
and david spade joins us on the program
you want an mtv award is that it well
i mean that's the one i actually won but
well i won it with farley but i that was
for best duo
we beat will smith and martin lawrence
for bad boys that was a real big click
baiter back then uh gotta be careful if
you beat will smith i just you know he
may come back after you yeah you gotta
beat him first yes what happened is i
was up for a couple emmys and golden
globes and i lost all of them like it
was like a beating i didn't look at the
numbers but the final numbers i'm sure
were bad
but do you prepare a speech
um
grotesquely yes
[Laughter]
i mean
do you have one good joke like i usually
have something
but it you know
embarrassingly when i'm leaving and they
see like the cbs receipt come out of my
coat and they're like is that your
speech i'm like no i just didn't know if
they were short on time they want me to
go long or something
but i did have a few little snappers to
say but i i um i got smoked actually the
grosser one was the emmys because they
said david hyde piers and i started
it was like slow motion it was just like
a false move like a block you know yeah
and it was just enough to where everyone
was like
when you're a presenter
how much freedom do you have to write
what you want to
write oh it's pretty loose um
i mean they want the comedians to come
spiced up a little bit i think the
oscars are smart when they
they pepper me if there's no host they
pepper comedians throughout and they
give me each like three minutes instead
of like 20 seconds so you could do a
little razzle dazzle or you present with
another i think i did one with tina fey
once we did like a little
a little bit and then uh
yeah so they let you screw around a
little bit the golden globes are looser
but do you get together with
chris rock and sandler like let's say
you're going to present would you then
who do you bounce your lines off of
before you go on stage
um
i yeah something like that i will check
in with that it depends on what it is
but
with
rock does
the the the big shows and he kind of
knows the drill we're a little different
than delivery but i will try to send him
stuff too i mean when he does
those things he'll go practice it and uh
go out to a club so maybe i'll
try to throw them a little doozy here
there but you know it doesn't always
work but it's good to have some feedback
for people or just to re-confirm
something works like
we went to the comedy cellar recently
and i was like i like that one that one
that one that's just someone in case
you're in your head going i don't know
if that one's but someone else likes it
you go okay good
how do you know when a bit's not working
um the crickets are part of it um the
deafening silence um sometimes they're
sort of laughing because they want to
laugh they're on your side i would you i
would usually sandwich it i'm kind of on
tour and we just did a bunch of midwest
shows and i'll sandwich a new thing in
between old stuff and
if it dips down too much i know it's
i just gave it every chance in the world
you know
i've got the crowd on my side and then
you throw in a new one and if it it plus
somewhere undercooked you know you have
to practice them it's hard to practice
them on the road i just did a netflix
special and it's an hour it took me to
get together for two years
and i have to sort of change it
overnight so i think i i still do some
of the special
and then i do some new stuff but i also
owe the crowd to stuff that works you
can't just sit there act like you're at
the improv you know
how often do you blame the crowd for not
getting your great humor
well i haven't blamed me yet
but um i feel it's coming because
i just go i walk up stage ago this crowd
man
no it's me i can tell because sometimes
as it comes out i really like it and
i'll stick with it if i like it but
sometimes
the crowd decides and i just go i i had
a lot of hope for this one just it is
not clicking
the toughest comedian you've ever had to
follow is who
oh
you know
there's anywhere from the big ones
because the comedy store you're always
going on it's like a rotation of good
people
and you can follow sebastian who kills
you can follow rock do and pop in um
or you can follow anybody and also
there's there's newer ones that you
don't know that really crush and then
you get caught off guard
and then you're supposed to be the good
one and they're like this guy hasn't
done anything and he's way better than
you and i'm like i know well it's hard
to explain
but if you follow somebody who bombed
can you
is the etiquette allow you to comment on
the comedian who bombed
i don't
really dennis miller
used to say
like if he does a corporate gig and the
guy introduces him
and it's just the most flat boring thing
dennis'll walk up and go thanks jim for
whipping them into a frenzy
so that one that old chestnut sometimes
oh by the way you did your dennis miller
impersonation fritzy has been working on
a david spade oh
really yeah
yeah very briefly okay here you go yeah
you guys lost the enemy last night
is that how i laughed
oh horrible no wonder the girls are
scattering my hearing is going though
oh
that's a good one
and who did you lose to uh good morning
football on the nfl network oh okay
with hey i watched that one
i split it up don't worry i split it up
i know but i mean you sounded like yeah
of course they won like it
it didn't sound like it's well that's an
upset i would say it's four against one
but you have your guys so you know it's
pretty even but uh listen i've been
there man i've been at those emmys is
there an emmy is there a ceremony yeah
and you went
it's last night and where was it new
york
you drove all the way to new york three
hours
to lose
oh stinger all right i know i got a
party bus
oh boy yeah
was it a little quieter on the way back
no no no no win or lose we celebrate
david you go this is a celebration it is
of losing yeah it is i i i don't want to
say this but go ahead okay um
that is good by the way you have a great
show i'm going to give you a pep talk no
no i'm good i don't need it
have you been any sam oh weren't you
just in a hustle yeah
yeah i saw hustle yeah the new wait if
you saw it then you knew i was in it
yeah but i wanted to make i just want to
make sure you would brag about it do you
think i'm that good of an actor that you
didn't realize that that was me acting
in the sandler movie in fact i don't
even know what character you played
because you blended in so well yeah yeah
i played with you you're good yeah
you're good it has a lot of stars in it
i'm calling you a star all you stars in
the sports world are in it
and it's a good movie i just saw it hat
did you go to the uh bot mitzvah for
sandler's door
you did yeah what did i miss because i i
couldn't go
you made your way to the sports emmys
[Laughter]
um
i know they weren't really giving out
trophies that night but i i did say it
was fun because it's always like uh
you know there's a good singer and you
it's the the best part is to see adam so
stressed because he's running around
this is a daytime ceremony and he has
lines you know it's very complicated
these ceremonies they have lines they
sing they go back and forth his daughter
has a great voice she sings uh
and then that's two hours and he has to
according to all the people coming and
then you come home then there's the
rager
and he was out front like directing
traffic because people were it was hard
for them to get in he's not oh my god i
love it i scream out the window adam i
love it so much because he's so mad who
is the musical act that i miss oh uh
halsey and charlie puth oh
okay that's that's big time there it's
big time and they uh
i don't think he pays them i think
they're very nice what i don't know for
sure what celebrities did i miss out on
i think i'm the only gets paid to go but
um there was uh
just a little stipend dan just to
get me out of the out of the house help
you out a little bit but like is is
conan there tom hanks there
uh last year i mean last time was with
his other daughter my mom was flirting
with dustin hoffman she was at our table
and uh she told him he's in her third
favorite movie and i was like waving her
off me and conan were like mom this
these aren't this is how compliments go
wait your mom's hitting on dustin
hoffman well not um yes
well she was competing about his movie
tootsie was almost as good as amadeus
and i'm like well just say it's the best
one like no one's gonna quiz you on it
later there's no fact checking just and
then he but he was very nice to her and
that was that was when adam um
yeah
yeah he sang and my mom was all into him
and pushed dustin into a wood chipper
when he came on stage
she was like oh who's the guy with the
tattoos and i'm like well
so he had a good run but this one was
you know a lot of uh celebrity types and
also the kids were like
his older daughter is 16 so her friends
are like from euphoria ish you know
they're like oh they look 35 and they're
running around and my daughter's 13 and
she's like are these adults or kids like
i don't i don't know what's going on
was jennifer aniston there
jennifer anderson was uh there oh damn
it i knew it i knew it she was a
sweetheart yeah she's so nice and you
probably see her on all the movies right
yeah
yeah she calls me the sports guy
yeah that's good i'll take it it's all
right i mean it's a blow-off but i mean
i i'm all right with it did you make
your way into
mystery murder mystery no because
aniston decides who's in those movies
not sandler
yeah i got i got c blocked by her
do you have any is there any sports
stuff in those movies where no you
wouldn't fit yeah you don't have to play
sports no i've been serious before yeah
you could play like a coach no i've been
i got range
coach or
talk show host of sports i could have
done tommy boy i could have done that
with f
yeah no i said yeah
my part was easy i just had to sit there
and go what yeah all you had to do was
not laugh like you had to be i just had
to not ruin tanks
has that ever happened though with
farley where he would do something and
then you screw it up by laughing and
then you're like oh my god you got to do
it again oh of course but i i posted a
clip once i'll probably do it again
where there's one part in the movie that
someone sent me a clip i don't know
where they get them where i go
i go we're doing all this stuff and all
you say is no he him like a nice guy and
and he doesn't know i'm going to say it
like that and he starts laughing so hard
and ruining the take that i start
yelling at him
because if we finally got it right and
he's off camera laughing or like
uh but it you know there's so many
outtakes man i wish they should they
would put a movie that would be great
and you had rob lowe on your podcast
with yeah dana carvey yeah today is jeff
goldblum yeah last week was dennis
miller who was hysterical of course
but what's the best story that was never
told about saturday night live behind oh
wow
um
that you guys have done this part it's
you and dana carvey talking about
saturday night live you guys go behind
the curtain there yeah we talk about
comedy and then we always wind up going
back to snl because we have either a
host on or a writer or a we had a lot of
good norm stories with jim downey who's
the writer forever there or did we can
update i didn't know
they fired jim
and then norm just went with him they
didn't fire norm
um i didn't know sandler and farley got
fired um
because i stayed next year
and uh they i found it later just
because they were doing so well in the
movies
i i think nbc wanted them
to go
and wanted to change you know over to
will ferrell and the new people and
i didn't even know that then i heard
that i thought oh that's weird because i
was sort of in the mix what was your
first impression of will ferrell on
saturday night live
uh
hey guys
that was an impression um no uh we
actually one time will ferrell and i he
was first of all the first impression
was he was great he's he's a first
ballot hall of famer over there like i
i we went had a burrito one time because
i was trying to get to know the new guys
i'm like let me take you out and when he
got there i already ate which i always
do and he goes did you eat already i go
uh yeah
that's so weird i shouldn't even say
this what did i do all the time and so
he thought that was peculiar
and then uh he did this getting off the
shed sketch that first week when yells
at a kid off camera he did that for us
oh he did oh my god
and why is it so funny it's so great and
then he just kept being better and
better i was i was on the show that year
but i was sort of uh on the outskirts
doing i had five minutes a week to do
whatever i wanted so i didn't really do
sketches
and i would just go down there and watch
it i was like this guy's got some game
by the way the netflix special i got a
chance to watch it nothing personal
streaming now and the podcast is called
fly on the wall with dana carvey and uh
i love the impersonation of the crab i
sent you a text oh yeah you sent me i
was gonna say you sent me a nice message
about
the special
and yeah that was when i was stuck in a
house with too many crabs and they
didn't care
the people didn't care the four-star
hotel which was four out of a thousand
didn't care
and and i go i have so many crabs
there's like 50 and he goes i know
they're crazy i go
i know but can they not be in my house
he goes ha ha it's crab season
but nobody cares it was a real shoulder
struggle i know but can they not be in
my house they go oh wouldn't that be
nice and then they leave
but yeah thank you and i'm getting ready
for fantasy football um
so you know and you're on tour
i'm on tour i'm doing um we just did
cincinnati
uh michigan and chicago was great and
now
i just have different ones coming up
it's on my website
[Laughter]
yeah where is kyler coming back tell me
because you know all this stuff yeah
he's coming back i'm an easy wait are
you all in on the cardinals i i want to
be i don't know it's a good team because
it's kind of different you know not
everyone's for the cardinals
yeah
yeah
i like kyler yes and i want him to do
good and he can do good but man
that's that last game they didn't do
well and then the suns in the last game
was a whole different are you a phoenix
suns guy too
yeah i was until they botched that last
game i bailed out i pulled the rip cord
i was like who am i for now
i'm trying to guess who's going to win
it all so i can glom on to that golden
state
oh it is i know but the other one's got
some tough defense gonna ruffle me yeah
of course
i don't know what i'm talking about i
know you don't i know
well dan great to talk to you
oh you gotta run or i gotta run both
okay uh dan say hi to the guys there if
they're allowed uh
yeah they're there they're they're
waving the losers are waving to you
right now you guys last year in fantasy
i'll tell you on my last round i didn't
know who anyone was and i picked takashi
69
anyway no all right bye guys got to run
on that one that one's not good yeah
keep it in okay all right okay that's
david spade the uh netflix special it's
nothing personal
and the podcast is fly on the wall with
dana carve